bill first of all thank you for doing
real time with bill maher you did a
great job I had a great time this is the
first time I work with you in years
let's talk about that here's what I
remember and to me it was your first
time on stage you might have it your
fifth I don't know the first time I ever
went on cindex comedy you were hosting
you went up that you work for your dad
who's a dentist at the time yeah and you
just work exactly the core of what you
do now which is you work you were pissed
about your job and you didn't like it
and you came down and I said dude you
have got to come back here do you
remember that no no I remember I asked
you how do I keep doing this and you I
still have the piece of paper somewhere
I think it's my parents house you wrote
on a little piece of paper the number
with Rita's name yeah next comedy stuff
read a choice and I still have that
somewhere I still describe for my
earlier stuff and that I'm in your
scrapbook yeah well yes someone else I
named in mine hand ready gets in your
stress all right that's right you were
always nice you always a nice guy that's
always encouraging you was I yeah you
were you were too he gave me one of my
first paid gigs when used to host the
kowloon wednesday night Oh noxee did
tuesday night there was the whole Peck
dressed too so that was the whole
facking order would you did open mic on
Monday night and then the big deal was I
remember some people from my my open my
class got to do your Wednesday show at
the Kyle moon before I didn't I just
never feeling like such a fail and
failure like I didn't get to be five
minutes isn't that there's at a Chinese
restaurant and then when you finally
called me on and I remember being so
nervous the first time I went on a show
that wasn't an open mic because I felt
like the crowd is more forgiving like
they knew that you weren't a
professional and that's the first time I
went on a professional show I just built
it up in my head the expectation that
the crowd was gonna have of like oh
they're back than me to be funny and
it went well thank God and then that's
over how much yeah what was your bit
tell me a bit you do I don't remember
though bit what I remember the the crowd
it was like sort of half-full Wednesday
you know yeah and I remember you
bringing guys up and then I remember the
guys I was working with like Todd Parker
and Lolita and Robby Prince and being
able to be like oh I can put them on my
resume yeah I work with these guys I was
such like a huge thing is it that funny
how life is like actually one of them
said hello to me which was awesome you
know there's a snapshot in time here
here's a time where you're thinking oh
guys in my improv or my comedy class or
getting on this Wednesday night show
that no one gets paid for yeah before me
my career's over and I'm thinking I'm
hosting the show I've made it yeah you
know any well any what I both have some
more things to do ya know the process is
you got to go through all those dice
again I started off with a great group
Patrice O'Neal rest his soul Dane Cook
oxy brothel Robert Kelly Bob Marley
there was a bunch of really I was lucky
I came home a bunch of really really
funny guys yeah
we were able to lose a crowded field
yeah what so anyways fast forward here I
had a great time here man
well I'm glad you did I wanted to talk
to you about one issue speaking of
crowded fields that's not a train that
move enough there's a train going by
the Pope last week in the Philippines
said that you got to use the birth
control everybody and I was thinking
about you because I know you've talked
about population control before and he
kind of backtracked a little bit the
next week he said too bad but don't
breed like rabbits I don't know why I
just gave the post incorporated Italian
but what do you think about population
world population is completely out of
control multiplied I think we did that I
think I think we achieved that goal and
it's time to move on to something else I
mean it's just gonna get worse and worse
and worse
like I think we need to kind of curb the
babies for a minute let's an older
people die off you know and I don't know
I think I could good numbers about I
don't know about 500 million oh really
sound like the oceans come back yeah but
how do you choose some space but you're
not talking about death panels you're
just talking about attrition yeah just
you know birth control them birth
control old people die somebody falls
off a ladder right you gradually you
know you taper it up here's what I think
maybe get rid of seat belt I mean
there's some things we could do to
medicine all these diseases we're trying
to stop is nature actually keeping us in
check but we can contemplate like love
and loss in our own mortality so we
think these diseases are bad they are
bad they but animals get them all the
time and it keeps them in check and we
stopped all of that get rid of medicine
get rid of medicine get rid of a healthy
life eat well get rid of medicine I
wouldn't be talking to you right now I
should not be here I had a ruptured
appendix in 1980 I should have died
under a stack of wool blankets on a
prairie but I did eat a green jello good
and know Here I am just walking around
taking up space driving a car load on a
river in my own way adding my hold of
the ozone layer I mean I don't know what
the solution is but
you know I don't know I'm trying to you
know I'm trying to be a good guy
filbert we're glad you made it thank you
for having me dude let's come on man
bringing it God bring it